how's it going best my name's beard ha
and welcome to I don't want to say it
right
Friday's my beard I'm really sorry bros
i missed you i miss you alive but
sometimes it's just really hard for me
to get out sometimes always it's really
hard for me to get these out on time but
hey a great man once said life is life
no no no Nona what's that that's a song
well then sing it that was [ __ ]
beautiful man ha ha oh I've done some
vlogging while I'm here in LA and I
thought he bros maybe are interested in
what I'm in doing so so I haven't
brought that much of all the cool stuff
that happened but hey uncool staff or a
cool to know well [ __ ] anyway um enjoy
don't kill the dragon ride it
they make great transportation that's
goin bread my name is Bert okay so we're
in LA finally and it's really nice it's
kind of dark and creepy right now and
they're ice people look at John yeah
how do you like LA so far Maya I show my
butt to it hey we're gonna go shopping
and then we have a lot of stuff to do
while we're here in LA I'm gonna show
you more later I'll see you then okay
let's go yeah yeah yo yo yo what up in
TVs my crib welcome welcome to my little
piece of heaven now what do you want see
first man we got we got birdhouses we
got lights
we got dog we have cameras good action
oh there's someone special wants to meet
you
there's a special bird this is this is
the love my life don't ever call me to
me okay she's shy
she's shy that's okay he can be shy so
you can't have a bumpin pimp pad without
right yeah okay I'm taking over this I'm
sorry
but yeah ken is here first time in LA
skank
I'm my second time another actually I
don't think about it you should be
scared it was your first flight and it
was scary right Daryl yeah poor Ken he's
always shaking shake it was some way man
the smell like tuna fish next to me it's
rough it's rough say I'm I might as well
even though Ken did a really good job I
want to show what's going on so this is
why I'm sitting this table she said
don't put anything on because it's
antique and of course I I followed her
everyone has to say something
ken your turn I love bacon okay that's
enough Maya system you're so American
Ken where are we going guys we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
party it's my party I never had a party
for me it's so awesome
I had a party once but no one came and
then I cried so I hope it's gonna be
better
ken are you coming to my party come with
your party okay so ken is coming to my
party so I guess is okay can say
something funny
now the sexiest man alive
that's right ken can I get a hand to you
your your one pointing back sorry sorry
did you want something
forget it she's done okay I wasn't even
filming you I'm sorry were you doing
something I just stand here look at
these beautiful it smells so good let me
smell them give them a good smell Kent I
know my Amitha cometh not you know if
you only smell I'm taking a picture
really oh here we go
oh there's beers people I can he could
not thank one beer don't don't judge I'm
here with this beautiful man oh I got
the flash on and I could do that
mmm thinking stay please dumb God give
it again I said Romeo take me somewhere
hello I'll be waiting
let's go yeah I'll be the Prince and you
be the princess love story baby just say
yes just just say it okay so we're at
this ley-line
we're going through the castle it looks
a lot smaller than I thought it would be
there's ducks so I feel at home and yeah
it's a lot of people I haven't seen any
rides yet I don't know what's up with
that
ah oh yeah the doctor Doc's are pretty
sweet how's my hair beautiful so we're
going this scary ride number two I
always seen one denied I thought it will
be appropriate I guess you're playing
game wait oh my god ah are you okay that
girl it's gonna be fine I was back there
it's great hey do you want my crown
you're so special I changed my mind
what the hell is going on
don't worry imagine he's not making fun
of me
I'm pretty sad you better this guy who
knocked on the door he said he wanted a
bourbon little mini baby sorry that's
blog ever we're waiting for Ken and TD
Smith to arrive um we've been waiting
forever
ken was i I'm so hungry oh he doesn't
come can you're dead to me
until you're Ives here uh better
I'm just rustic and to do something
funny
I don't even know
great job cab Helen are you okay there
yeah I better take a big be friends and
be like something funny much often for
Ken oh hey you want to shoot let's do it
no do it down
oh yeah Trina yeah wait how's it go oh
hey Jess see just how to do it girl okay
so one just like it
okay ken is leaving don't go can buy
biking that's just when you get there
there goes a great man living with a
great hair great hair great shirt a
great smile
I wanted to shave after that
I can't really see it anyway really done
guys like I'm this window is a kid shut
up you can't tell me what to do how's it
going rez going to go over there um are
you going I don't know I'm going to take
some pictures at a photo shoot I get to
be model he'll stop at you bro I know
I'm pretty
I mean I'm family whatever so we're
gonna sell some t-shirts for you bros
that are really sweet I think you're
gonna you're gonna like them they're way
better than the old ones
it's funny cuz here in LA there's always
like someone wanting something to do
here it's I hate you want to do a collab
or hey do you want to do this or I photo
shoot come here it's not it's not tough
job or it's not like it's boring or
anything but I gotta say here in LA it
kind of feels like a job YouTube
honestly it's really weird
you know I started this just to [ __ ]
play video games and Here I am like
going across LA to do different stuff
and it's exciting and it's fun but at
the same time it's like what the [ __ ] am
i doing
you know it's all weird
I don't sure what my opinion about it is
yet if this is what I want or if I just
want to sit in my little dungeon and
Italy and play video games all alone all
I know for sure is that I love it like
so far right so so so I'm having a lot
of fun there's a lot of people who
um I don't know nevermind I just wish
Ken was here you know I missed that son
of a [ __ ] but otherwise everything is
perfect going back in two weeks I should
end this vlog now hey hey yo you look
pretty lame I like your face
here come in all right brother hope that
was enjoyable somehow I don't know um
last but not least I am very proud and
happy to announce that I launched a
collection of the really awesome
merchandise you bros have been asking
for new t-shirts forever I have not
updated anything in like I don't know
how long so it's about damn time and
it's a limited offer so if you want to
get at one of the t-shirts now's your
chance
or time that's the only time do it so
first link in the description Bros and
it will take you there and the model
pittance is gonna take over while I talk
about it a little bit so that they are
really quality t-shirts I wore them
myself the fabric it feels really good
the print is perfect like it won't wear
off or it's not something cheap or
anything like that it's really cool I
really have been excited about it also
got these cool little an iPhone case
it's pretty sweet but yeah I just wanted
to finish off by saying thank you both
for being sping yo being a fan being
supportive I can tell you bros enough
how much I appreciate it we're almost
already at 7 million bros which is
laughs where the hell does all you brush
come from I don't get it my butt
actually like that that's kind of cool
but anyway come in give me a hug
actually even better let's do a brofist
so here's from being awesome bros stay
awesome but I know you will
pheromone activate